join our series we call it the dish
we're taking a look this morning at how
a celebrated restaurant has thrived
through challenge after challenge single
thread is the name of the restaurant in
northern california's wine country was
named one of the 50 best restaurants in
the world last year i want to go there
chef kyle connaughton serves
japanese-inspired cuisine created with
ingredients grown on the restaurant's
own farm run by his wife and co-owner
that would be the lovely katina lilia
luciano got a taste of their exquisite
cuisine and discovered how they're
expanding their reach
what do we have here
these are our spring peas in the heart
of american wine country instead of a
glass of chardonnay you'll find the
freshest peas pods flowers and all
straight off the trellis i love these
flowers are these edible too they most
certainly are katina and kyle
connaughton's new farm property is home
to bees chickens fresh vegetables
destined for the kitchen and a host of
flowers
something we love so much about the
kitchen is that they're not trying to
manipulate the hard work of the farm
they're really highlighting it and
celebrating it the couple's path to
three michelin stars began when they
were teenagers were you always
passionate about food yeah well we have
this long vision being together since we
were teenagers and we had this dream and
we fell in love with this area and
17 years later opened a restaurant about
a block away from where we first really
kind of dreamed about one day having a
restaurant here have we always loved
food i'm pretty sure we have yeah
it has been a remarkably successful
journey they spent years learning their
trades in europe and asia and their time
in japan especially had a profound
influence on their culinary style and
the taste from single thread's acclaimed
kitchen i am so excited oh my gosh i'm
excited to cook for you this is inspired
by
a tres leches cake which is like our
favorite dessert yeah that's my favorite
dessert too for sure this is like a
savory version of that just starting in
the middle not afraid all the way down
get a little bit of everything at the
table it's quite the ride of color
flavor and texture this was completely
expressing itself in my mouth this is it
really is an expression of so much so
many flavors but recently that
achievement has been fraught with speed
bumps we certainly are no strangers to
crisis management
from wildfires that force people from
the region to the pandemic lockdowns
caused them to pivot to sending out farm
fresh veggie boxes and preparing meals
for first responders frontline and
farmworkers then just a single thread
was getting back on its feet we had a
fire in the middle of service in the
middle of our exhausts all the way
through from the stove up to the rooftop
and it's closed us down for two and a
half months of
repairs what is it that keeps you guys
moving
it's resilience yeah it's tenacity it's
the the punk rock teenagers that still
live deep within us
they're putting their past setbacks
behind them and expanding settling into
their new 24 acre farm and welcoming new
clientele to their second location the
plant-based little saint we wanted to do
something more casual in our community
that had more accessibility for locals
and visitors and that you could visit
more frequently
the connaton's life together is a lesson
to us all perseverance passion and
positivity underscored by their lifelong
love story our whole life revolves
around our work and we're so passionate
about it is it is such a mutual
appreciation for what each other does is
there a single thread or is there
or are there more is there a single
thread well no thread is just one really
it's a series of fibers woven together
and i think that is very true to who we
are as well for cbs mornings lilia
luciano healsburg california
beautiful just added another restaurant
to the bucket list she did i love a good
love story and i love people have been
teenagers that are still in love and i
love the teenage hair i was going to say
that as well i love that hair we love
that bring that back